I'm both a kickoff reporter and a
Schalke fan I've reported from almost
every Bundesliga stadium
but after six years covering every facet
of the game at the end of last season I
had enough
things got to me like how the game
revolves around money and the attitude
of some of my colleagues
I asked myself whether I was at fault or
was it the game itself but maybe she can
cure my cynicism hello hi nice to meet
you this is jodi Strauss she's flown
12,000 kilometers just to see her
favorite team my name is Jody Strauss
I'm from Maryville Missouri the United
States I am a professor by day and a
Bundesliga junkie by night a huge fan of
she'll go for and so this is my first
trip to the Belton's ensue off shelcha
hope we win today today Schalke take on
Stuttgart it's shall cos last home game
of the season there are still four hours
until kickoff so I show Jodie around
gills and kitchen she got hooked on
soccer during the 2006 world cup and she
got [ __ ] on the Bundesliga after
watching chaka play Bayern Munich
most of the games in the US are Bayern
Munich so they were playing Schalke and
I was lost after that I told them of
course and you can't pick who you fall
in love with but I saw Schalke play I
like the way they do the huddle they get
in a group and hot you know before the
game the working class team the
blue-collar ethic is part of the shock a
legend gone are the days when players
worked in the local coal mines but it's
still part of the club's Elua
you see that here at the Schalke fan
mile people here have a down-to-earth
manner that's characteristic of the Ruhr
Valley
ok
so what's it like watching a Bundesliga
game back in Missouri oh yeah 815 alarm
goes off pick it up I make some coffee i
turn on the TV start watch the game
actually I get on Twitter and I always
say first thing is right when the game
starts I say Nicole my boys in blue and
everybody retweets and then then I
cursed throughout the game I Twitter and
Google and when they score I stand up in
my living room all by myself and I sing
now and I signs even long after a stop
at the pub we continued to the stadium
used by Schalke until 1973 it was here
that the club celebrated their biggest
wins in the 1930s this turf is part of
Jacques rich tradition a glorious past
going back 100 years
half a century ago 60,000 fans packed
the stands here it was an era when the
game was about more than just the league
standings that's one thing i like about
shelke is he got that history there and
we don't get a lot of times in the
states had a thing one time Schalke 04
and somebody asked me why the 04 stood
for and I said that's when they were
founded and they said 2004 no 1904 so
yeah we we don't have that long
tradition sometimes in the states with
sports especially
jody Strauss has German roots back in
the 1900s her great-grandfather was 17
when he and his family moved from
Darmstadt to the US
we return to the Felton's arena where
Shaka are facing off against Dukat at
stake is a spot in the Champions League
here we catch up with Heights the two
met via social media and Heights
organized Judy's ticket for the game I
think so interesting did I sing
something no but I went like this I
didn't know the words sorry just dance
we head inside the stadium and had our
separate ways Jodi takes her seat up in
the stands I also saw my first Schalke
match somewhere up there these days I'm
more often behind the goal with the
other journalists this is Evan the
Schalke mascot I once did a report on
him and surprisingly he still remembers
me
but y de football clubs need a mascot at
all most are an invention of PR
companies like the foals of mentioned
Gladbach or the duisburg zebra it seems
to be pure marketing
just like this ball on a pillar every
televised Bundesliga game begins with
the same visual a Steadicam shoots the
ball with the Bundesliga logo zooms back
to the players coming out of their
changing rooms with the ball boys and
girls and then the referee picks up the
ball with a big smile every single game
since they began using this opening
sequence I found the start of matches
much more monotonous and weak for a week
it's the same music the same drum rolls
victory celebrations also look the same
maybe it's a blessing in disguise that
Schalke haven't won the championship
recently but at least Jodi's enjoying
herself I've always been fascinated by
the technology used in the game for
example what does this guy do I think he
takes care of the mini cameras attached
to the Nets but does he care about the
game or is he just worried about picture
quality
and what about this photographer is it
only about getting a spectacular shots
does it matter to him who scores and who
wins who knows maybe I'm just too jaded
to see the beautiful game for what it is
it's fast it's very fast I don't think a
lot of people appreciate at first
because they just see the scores but
once you watch it you see the way the
speed move and the strategy of the
passing it the goal is the final it's
overwhelming but the plays are it's hard
to me it's art emotion especially when
it's Playboy today wasn't to be shell
cos day they lose one meal to strip
cards but TV viewers won't see the
disappointed shot the players walking to
their changing room it seems some in the
media don't want to show any weakness
but Jodi at least takes away a very
positive experience we lost oh but I was
telling someone not we lost but I'm
still a winner cuz I got to see my team
got to see the arena it was a great day
trading after my day with Jody Strauss I
thought about my experiences with
Schalke I thought back to 2001 when
shopping with champions for a few
minutes they'd finished their last game
thought they had the title but Bayern
snatched it away in the final seconds of
the season I remember consoling one of
those tough Schalke supporters who was
sobbing on my shoulder it was then I
realized that soccer is about people and
emotions
you'll never lose your love
to cheer and you you're heartbroken but
you always know there's always the next
game there's always the next season and
that's what I kind of like to is the end
of the season you maybe didn't get where
you wanted to be there's always next
season and you always start every season
thinking this year we're going to wind
it all we're gonna win it all we're
gonna do the triple so thanks to duty
for a memorable day at Schalke and for
helping restore my faith in the game